and we go in life like life life
or with it with Griffin
let's go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
as usual welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to rip and
whip
a lot of stuff on today's episode you
know
gotta keep doing it uh let's see GTA 5
is coming out great video game James
Cameron uh talking about disaster films
he's kind of upset that they think he's
gonna make a submergible one you know an
iPhone sold for 190
000 and are we not worried enough about
aliens
real feelings
[Music]
yeah I I like when I could hear my voice
is good
is it GTA 6 I'm sorry six is GTA 6
coming out I don't know I don't know how
to do the Roman numerals thank you in
the chat welcome back welcome back to
River with Griffin and everybody uh when
my voice is feeling milky I like to like
you know milk it a little bit you know
what I mean
you know so anyways feeling it today
thanks for being here on Roofing with a
Griffin and as always I appreciate you
guys and uh you know what you do when
you're here you know uh thank you for
subscribing it really helps to subscribe
so subscribe share do all that stuff you
know I'm doing it late you have to hit
the notifications so you know when I
come on live uh I got a pregnant wife so
my days are weird so I can't just come
on when I want to
um twitch you know I still game I'm
twitching this for as long as I can
before my life is full of diapers
um and you know
patreon I am doing content I didn't do
last week's episode but I am gonna do a
spoiler of the whole season of Idol with
the weekend and what's her name Lily
Rose Depp or whatever the hell her name
is man what a train wreck but I want to
really dive into it so if you never saw
the series
and you don't care about spoilers then
you're gonna watch that if you already
saw it and you want to hear my thoughts
on it so we will be doing that I'm gonna
do it probably either later today and I
like to do that live on Twitch and then
I'll post it to
um
what do you call the patreon
if you if you are you know you could be
a twitch subscriber you know or a
YouTube subscriber member or you could
be uh uh patreon and you'll get that
extra content they'll already have up
the last one I did was about
um I went through all the Black Mirror
episodes so if you're into spoilers I'm
trying to like you know Rebrand so it's
like spoiling with Griffin or spoiler
alert or whatever like that so we'll
start doing uh that kind of stuff uh
there and um if you're in Chicago guys
Chicago people where you guys at holler
at me let me know what's up Chicago
people I'm gonna be in Chicago this
Friday and Saturday at the Rosemont
Zanies Zanies in Rosemont get your
tickets now you can go to airgriffin.com
to hit the link there on my trash
website but it'll be there uh and then
you go and then next week after that on
I don't know if it's next is it next
week it might be yeah it is it's gonna
be next week
July 28th anybody in the California area
if you're in Irvine I'm gonna be at the
Irvine Improv just one night two shows
one night Irvine Improv Friday night uh
on July 28th so come check me out there
too so thank you very much for all that
you do
okay so welcome back to we're from with
Griffin uh thanks for listening
subscribing and all that stuff everybody
in the chat that's watching live thank
you uh you know you guys I appreciate
what you guys do being here you know
this podcast is
for the people that have come in for the
first time you're like oh what is this
you know I talk about everything and
anything it's riffing with Griffin
sometimes I'm funny sometimes I'm
introspective sometimes I'm serious
sometimes I even cry other times
um you know you know you can it is what
it is so for the new people so welcome
for the old people you know what we do
thanks for being here all right
um what's going on this week uh yeah I
want to wait Rachel was gonna come on
but I'm gonna wait for her
oh she yeah she was I'm gonna wait for
her because you know as we're going
through our pregnancy and you know she
actually doesn't want me like talking
revealing too much stuff I feel like I'm
too open about certain things you know I
mean but you just forget you're just
talking you know what I mean but like
she'll come on and reveal what she wants
to reveal but it's been it's going well
you know it's a lot to it when your
first time going through this process at
this point you know we're at like almost
13 weeks I think it's 13 weeks today I
don't know something like that but you
know it's like man what a process it is
it's like a friend for anybody that's
um out there you know you're doing it
for the first time I I know where you're
at you know you're just like you know
you're scared and nervous and you're
just kind of like what's going on and
then like for the guy
you know you're you're you're taking on
these all these things that you
necessarily weren't taken on before
whatever you weren't doing in your
relationship say for household stuff I
don't know whatever Arrangement you have
with your partner you're taking on
whatever you weren't doing you got to do
now it's it's a lot you know but it's
like I don't know I feel how do I feel
you know being at this stage in my life
like you know so so sometimes I'm
downstairs and I'm like
um you know I wouldn't always do the
dishes every single day sometimes you
just leave the dishes it's just her and
I so I'm like whatever so now I know
it's like oh no I gotta take care of
this because I have to cook tomorrow so
now I'm like you know washing dishes
every day like every single day uh put
you know on taking stuff out the
dishwasher every single day and like you
know or whatever you know whatever your
routine is or the things you do so now
I'm going to the I'm going to the market
more often like you know because like we
haven't actually been ordering food that
much anymore because I just do a lot of
cooking you know and then like um
you know now you're trying to also
determine like oh I don't want to buy
too much of this because I don't want it
to go to waste it's like you know it's
like okay what does she like all right
let me make sure I get enough of this
and then it's like oh you you don't want
to get too much because like I say you
don't want to go to waste like she's
like celery so it's like all right so
let me just get one thing of the celery
she likes the fresh organic stuff so I
you know I chopped off the ends and all
that and I made it ready put it in a big
bag and then she ate it all with some
peanut butter and I was like oh okay so
she really likes that so now I'm gonna
go back and get like two or three of
those because I know they're gonna
they're not gonna go to waste you know
it's that kind of stuff you know what's
funny too that you learn uh I think that
I think that the process for a guy for
the husband or you know whatever you
want to call yourself the other person
that's not having the baby how about
that
um
you're learning like patience and how to
deal with uh okay like so I made a meal
yesterday and I try I I bought some
right ways you don't like spices so I
bought some like some kind of
all-purpose spice thing and I thought oh
this is gonna be cool so then I like put
it on this I made a steak you know and I
grilled it on my Traeger grill thanks
shout out to Traeger they gave me this
great Grill
beautiful Grill I recommend getting a
Traeger grill anyways
free plug for them
um so and then so you know you know how
it is like you I just I seasoned this
the night before I made all these
vegetables you know you know what I mean
and then like she got it and I could
tell she didn't like it
you know she was like I don't like these
spices and I don't like this and then I
thought to myself I was like oh this is
actually training for when you get
something for your kids and they just
don't like it and you can't take it
personal so I was like ah so I knew it
was my fault because I was like oh I
tried something new with the spices and
I know she don't I thought it was gonna
be but I actually I didn't even really
like it you know but it was like it was
like it's telling me like oh this is how
it's gonna be you know you know and I
you know how kids can be I've seen it
you know you're like hey you want this
and they're like oh I don't like that
but maybe you slaved over a stove for
five hours and then this kid is like I
don't want that crap you it's like
training you for that I think that like
uh a pregnant woman is like preparing
you for like hey be patient don't take
[__] personal uh you have to look out
for more than just you you know what I
mean so I was like
so I was like okay so now I know it's
like with her it's just salt pepper
maybe a little bit of oil you know to
put like on the vegetables and I know I
put too much oil it's like I'm learning
all these things and it's like that's
that's like what's good cooking is good
cooking like making something you
prepared for some contest or is it good
cooking is making what the people you're
cooking for what they really like which
you know you have to ask yourself which
one is it so
it's crazy
um
it's a lot of
it's a lot of uh it's it's a lot of it's
an adjustment I'll say that it is a huge
adjustment that I am all prepared for I
mean I don't know if if I if I had to
look back look back I'd be like oh maybe
I wish I would have done this earlier uh
you know
because I had some heartbreak in my
early in my life where it's like I was
in this relationship for like six seven
years broke my heart and then I was like
wasn't doing what I wanted to do in my
life and so then I really focused on me
it was like really like it was all about
me and my career you know and so
you know stuff happens in your life you
know and so then but I think back
because like dude I'm 51 y'all so it's
like I'm starting
I should be thinking about man I'm gonna
be done in 10 years or whatever right
you know but it's like this is how I did
it so I have to deal with it so it's
like I'm making all this stuff a part of
my life I mean it's different it's a
different transition I don't know all
you people out there who are parents
already you know you hear me you're like
oh you think it's hard now dude wait
till you know what I mean it's like it's
like I'm one thing I'll say is I'm ready
for it I like all challenges and I and
because I related to like
um the entertainment business the
entertainment business is very
challenging okay it's very challenging
so here we are
here we are and I'll keep you guys
posted uh on my journey and how it's how
it's going and how I'm preparing myself
for it so
anyway
all right let's see uh let's go to some
comments guys
get to the comment section
um what are we at here
all right we got some comments you know
a lot of haters man there's so many the
haters are on out in force these days
I don't know I guess they got nothing
better to do
okay so we got this guy Edwin Garcia he
comments a lot Griffin my dude to new
I'm new to your podcast and I gotta say
that your intro is dope AF I love how
you talk about the culture movies and
video games all right thank you I
appreciate that
um
oh here's another Matt Rife comment and
some girl has uh what's her name Destiny
rue2187 has he ever thought about dating
mid-20s girl from Ohio or Kentucky that
is willing to follow him where he wants
to live some little little grown girl
have the same kind of dreams
I mean it's like every week now somebody
finds this podcast with Matt and they
you know have a comment about
that they're the one for him it's like
it's so funny
oh I got this really crazy Instagram
message about Matt so
some lady hits me up and she's like hey
um you know she's like
um I I need to get in contact with Matt
because I I I've been talking to someone
that I thought was him and I got scammed
and I just want to make him aware before
I go to the police I didn't even respond
you know what I mean
imagine so he's super famous now he's
like famous famous now okay he's going
he's getting to the road like the next
thing you know he's gonna be an Avenger
or something right and then it's going
to be on a whole worldly level a whole
other level but in terms of like comedy
and like he's got Billboards on Sunset
so it's like so my thing is like Hey
listen
you know take some personal
responsibility and it's like a person
that I'd be like why would he talk to
you why would he ask you for money why
would he like whatever it is like
you think you're talking to that person
you're not and so
I'm not a fool you think I'm gonna be
like oh well let me get on this hold on
a second let me go call him hey bro
there's somebody pretending to be you
and someone got catfished and they're
mad and they want you to do something
about it like I'm sorry like like I
can't stand it that like people think
I'm gonna be the go-between
y'all I've been not could I be cooking
knowing stuff so I've been looking like
you know what I mean get my exercise on
be doing good
all right let's see uh uh oh I love this
one so Oscar
wilde891 born in 89 for context for
context but movies that changed
everything for me the Matrix Spider-Man
Pirates of the Caribbean Kill Bill ooh
those are actually really great choices
because uh last week I was talking about
how uh Indiana Jones it was one of the
most profound movie experiences of my
life is when I watched Indiana Jones the
first one the first movie I I was 9 10
years old and it changed my life I uh so
I'm asking people now I actually like
the The Matrix is a great one like the
Matrix changed the movies in my opinion
I mean it changed like the Matrix don't
get enough credit for how
how groundbreaking The Matrix was for
movie the movie experience so that was
great and Spider-Man the first
Spider-Man that's a good one too because
I remember watching the first Spider-Man
and thinking oh for the first time like
as an old person like it's a person born
in the 70s when you watched that first
Spider-Man you I was it was the same
sort of amazing feeling I had when I
watched Jurassic Park when you saw that
CGI for the first time so to be a comic
book collector like I collected comics
and then to watch what we really think
Spider-Man would look like on the screen
for the first time swinging around New
York it was amazing it was amazing it
was like Wow here it is like our
imaginations can actually be on screen
because when I grew up at a time when
that just wasn't a thing so like
everything was trash man there was like
a original Spider-Man movie was trash
you could see the freaking rope there
was a Captain America movie that was
crash even the Incredible Hulk
television show it's like you know
clearly
it was just a stronger dude you know
what I mean you know what I mean you
just had like it was this dude and then
it was a bodybuilder in green makeup you
know but we had to suspend our disbelief
way more and so there was a there was a
time when I was growing up where it was
like oh man it was just only cartoons
can show you what
that's why cartoons were so amazing like
Thundercats and uh you know He-Man and
all these things we would just watch
cartoons because that was the only way
we could see uh what it what you know a
lot sort of live action so then when it
really went to True live action and our
imagination anything in our imaginations
we can now show on screen I don't unders
I don't think you young people
understand how that transition for us
older generation Gen X people how that
that was like so it was an amazing time
for us because it was like oh man this
is it you know so anyways good good
comment
um
let's see
ah what we got here
let's see so Kyle Cali jury k-a-l-i I
don't know how to say your stupid names
isn't AI just humans inputting into a
system much like a search engine example
it would not give Expressions that it
deemed inappropriate with oddly which
oddly scene seems to lean to the left
that's human input not some
yeah artificial intelligence okay I kind
of know what you're saying
I think that I don't think it's true
artificial intelligence because first of
all I don't think they would release
that to the public yet anyway
but I do think it's a more enhanced
detailed speech recognition of like what
you're asking for like I actually don't
use Google anymore I use this chat
software that I have
and the way it interacts I like how you
can interact with it so oh I forgot to
mention so like today's the description
of the episode and thanks for all the
comments guys I'm gonna I'm gonna move
on from that but thanks for all the
comments like today's description of the
episode I made with the AI I wanted to
test it out I forgot to say that early
on yeah I wanted to say that early on so
so look I put in like
this is what what I so in that and I'm
gonna go through the chat history so you
can see like what I asked for you know
so I said I need a YouTube description
for my podcast episode here are today's
topics I'm discussing and I said Apple
iPhone sells an auction for 190 000 is
that a ridiculous purchase I said Grand
Theft Auto video game is going to cost 2
billion I'm gonna talk about that soon
uh a guy was trapped under a baseball a
a tarp and when they are covering the
field for rain and James Cameron is
upset that they think he's making a
movie so I put that in the chat into the
the AI right and then it pumped out
this whole thing but it was numbered
right so it was like section one section
two section three section four six and
five so then I said all I said to it was
make it shorter and then it did but it
had numbers on it right then I said
without numbers just a solid paragraph
and then it came up with that so I was
like and it's like very like as you can
see like I don't even talk like that but
I just wanted to use it to see how it is
I think it's a very helpful tool so I
like that
that interaction is what Google needs to
move to or people are gonna just use
this because I like the idea that if I'm
like like I'm searching for something if
I say I uh look for Red Jackets you know
and then it shows me red jackets and
I'll say uh oh you know what make them
longer make them um uh matching shirts
so you don't have to like do a whole new
search it's like a conversation you're
having with the AI
that you don't have to
you know go through ads and like you
know it's just giving you like direct
information you know like I got my
genetic test back you know you get the
genetic test from the pregnancy stuff
and I was like hey what does this mean
and then a I said woman I said something
I should worry about then it gave me
more information I was like oh so if
somebody has this does that you know
it's like this kind of chat conversation
you're having in the search so I think
that how you how it interacts with us I
think is where the future is going now
in terms of the thing learning itself I
don't know but if you think about this
there is so much information on the
internet okay about everything there's
encyclopedias
um dictionaries so so the the thing is
gathering the information from all this
stuff and there's so much information
that it's making it seem like it it's
having a real conversation with you
um but you know I I think that you know
we're moving in a good direction in
terms of that if you're not a person
that's afraid of it you know
um I guess somebody said we'll probably
be incorporated into Siri down though
this this crazy person in my chat called
downhill dad what a dumb name
um I'm just kidding another guy
um yes I think Siri should be like that
I think Siri should be an AI
or the more advanced day guys you can be
like hey you know it's like hey Siri
like already when you go like this I
already have a little like life hack for
you right now so if you're looking for
your phone right you go hey Siri
where are you
I'm here that's how I find my phone
if I leave my phone someplace in the
house and I can't find it I just go hey
Siri and it goes uh-huh and I go where
are you and it goes I'm over here and I
go oh there it is so I think that
like that kind of technology is like
where you can continue your search
questions I think is where the AI is
going to go for all these things because
as of right now like Google better
update because I don't know about you if
you have any I use this app called
Chatster
Chatster it's like an AI based app you
know it was like 69 for the whole year
and I was like I think it's where I
wanted to test it out I think it's worth
it right so then it's like so now I can
go you know it's gonna help me with my
podcast I'll be like uh all right I want
to talk about this this and this give me
a description uh give me a title for
this or hey or or maybe I need some
information about like uh you know like
if I'm going to like if I'm going to
talk about James Cameron I might ask it
uh list me James Cameron's movies in
order
oh wait I have to make a new channel
that's another thing to you to make a
new conversation that's interesting
all right here we go
um
list of James Cameron movies in order
why isn't it doing it
wait I think I have to start over
I don't know why it's doing that it says
it's saying something weird
let me try this again
hmm
the model's maximum context length is 4
000 tokens however you requested six
thousand tokens 14 in the matches six
thousand in the completion please reduce
the length of the message or completion
I don't understand what they mean by
that I'm gonna have to look to see it
right in the middle let's see there's
like there's still issues
[Laughter]
you know what I mean it still has issues
I don't know it's like
it's like if you're already talking
about something that you have to like
start a new one you have to it's a weird
it's a weird thing how how it works but
anyways let's go into the the other
stuff that I was going to talk about in
the app speaking of James Cameron let's
talk about James Cameron
um this is one of my Instagram stories
that I have today
um Instagram posts let's go to this I
hope you get do you guys like my uh
little
you know how I do that little social
media
um but you know what I don't like how
this looks though I mean what's going on
here why does this look like this you
see there's always something guys you
know there's always something
I want this to be
foam
yeah I cropped it so we want it to be
oh wait
boom and then the left should be well
there we go boom all right there now it
now is showing everything
that's weird anyways James Cameron I'm
working on things as we go
um so James Cameron's blasts offensive
rumors that he that he's intoxic
directed Titanic subversal submersible
disaster film
I got an issue with this James Cameron I
have an issue with you why is this so
out of the realm of possibility of
something that can happen huh like what
like why are you acting like you didn't
make already make a disaster movie about
one of the worst tragedies in American
history you think because you took so
long to make it it was like like what's
the what's the statue of limitations of
when it's something is inappropriate to
make about something this guy made a
love story about you know a tragic
accident and so many people died and
we're supposed to sit here and be like
like you wouldn't want to make this
movie
I mean what are we talking about this is
what we do in the United States Society
this is the this is the American way
we celebrate our triumphs and we mourn
our tragedies the same way we make
movies and television shows about them
I've talked about this before how many
911 references are there in really
terrible movies
I don't care how good the movie is or
how bad the movie is people they use 911
in like dumb spy movies plot points now
all the time kovid we're talking about
that all the time in movies they're
making reference to it in like movies
and television shows we do this all the
time we made a Boston Marathon movie we
may let you know you know what I mean
like there's so many movies that we make
like he's acting like this is so
terrible why
you who's more equipped to make a movie
about this than this guy
he already said himself he made over 30
trips down to down to the Titanic in
submarines to do research for his movie
and because this is something he was
interested in so yeah you know a
billionaire dies uh uh you know a kid
all these people that die you're like
all right yeah let's uh you know make a
movie about it so we can uh that's how
we learn things that's how we like go uh
this is a cautionary tale and we tell it
in a fictional form and based off a true
story so for him to be like virtue
signaling about like I am I am offended
that you would think that I would do
this hell yeah you would do it you
already did it
okay there's a family still suffering
from their grand great grandparents who
died in the Titanic and you made a movie
that made two billion dollars
what are you talking about
stop acting like you better than
everybody
it's and so that's how I get on him the
other side of it is hey everybody shut
up
why you getting on this guy even if he
was thinking about that oh now
everybody's got an issue oh this is
inappropriate but there's so much like
what are you talking about there's so
much other inappropriate things and
feelings and and stuff that people do
and and this is just one of those things
that people want to people wanna this is
the I'm a good person police there's a
I'm a good person Club out there in the
world I'm a good person
and I'm a good person club they're the
ones that have to support things and
don't use any common sense like they
have to support things on face value for
the internet without actually talking
about it body positivity is one of those
things like people like they go well I'm
a good person so I support body
positivity with no context with nothing
no it's not okay what like it's more
nuanced than just that
talking about health and and and people
being living longer and eating right and
exercising that is not wrong to talk
about
what you're saying is hey like fat
shaming and body positivity
there's a nuanced difference between the
two and then even though you would say
the same things about each you know
so that so that's what the good person
the good I'm a good person that that
movement in society right now this is
what that is right there they're like oh
well I would never I cannot support him
making a movie the people died six
people died okay what what what
we've made movies about other things
are you gonna are you gonna get on
everything that we do like is there is
there nothing we can make like this
Oppenheimer movie is coming out right it
came in did it come out already I think
it did
I don't know if I want to see it because
my my base knowledge of this is this is
the guy that convented the atom bomb
that we dropped on a country and killed
a bunch of people
why is that story being told
right
because it's like this is what we do
this is what we do
so all the it it's like if you're trying
to be
person all the time like it's more
nuanced than that man like be better
than that be better than that
so it's like James Cameron
just make your move if you are gonna do
that I'm sure it'll be great okay you
know Kudo you know it's like R.I.P to
the victims and maybe you making this
movie is gonna make the the expose
something about
you know that this submarine company or
or doing things like this in the future
and safety precautions maybe your movie
will shed a light on that right and then
maybe you who knows you know and then
more people will know about this I don't
know but it's like stop acting like it's
so out of the realm and then like I say
and everyone else stop acting like you a
good person all the time stop acting
like you're doing enough just by being
outraged being outraged is not enough to
make you a good person
that'd be like right now I look at you
know I'm just showing you videos of
homeless children being and I'm just I
can't believe there are homeless
children in the world but I'm not doing
anything to help them
stop having you you know you know what I
mean you're not a good person just
because
you're outraged
okay
let's move on
[Laughter]
man unbelievable right man
people are unbelievable
all right let's go where wait where am I
where's my stories man
um
oh let's talk about this one now this is
like if you're a gamer gamer nerds were
you gamer nerds at
demon
[Music]
oh see that's why I had that smaller
because of that stuff showed up anyways
it doesn't matter
so Grand Theft Auto 6 is coming out and
it's set to cost up to 2 billion dollars
to make it's the most expensive
entertainment product ever
two billion dollars to make it I'm
excited the last one Grand Theft Auto 5
I believe
let me see if
let's see if my chat will work now I
don't know why it's not working all of a
sudden I'm talking about it doesn't work
all right let's see when did Grand Theft
Auto 5 come out
I don't know why my thing's not working
this doesn't even make any sense
wow that's weird okay well let's just go
to Google and Google wins we're back to
Google
when did Grand Theft Auto 5 come out
all right let's see September 17
2013. wow
so
check this out
that was a 10 year game
when it came out and at the time I think
they said it cost like 500 million
dollars
and then and what a great game I think
I've played that game so many times from
beginning to end because it's just open
world beautiful lost to innocent based
in Los Angeles so I love driving around
and being like Oh man there's where The
Comedy Store is or oh this is where that
is you try to find your neighborhood
where you live and stuff it's like it's
crazy
um but it's it's like
it's incredible
you know so I can't wait to see what
this one's gonna be like like is are
they gonna incorporate AI or is it going
to be like like and how long are they
gonna have this game I mean I totally
like the idea that this game is going to
come out and then it's going to be
available for
10 years they're like that's how much
content that's how much
um Joy it's given people that's like
that programming is so Advanced and so
you know Rich the environment is so rich
and and that you'll be like oh we I can
continue that this game can continue to
go on for 10 years I'm sure they made
all their money back you know let's find
out that
let's find out that uh
how much profit did Grand Theft Auto 5
make
let's see what they're saying our code
contribution reports from take two
interactive GTA 5 has generated
7.7 billion dollars in revenue for the
company
so you invest 500 million dollars and
then 10 years later you you made that
and you turned that into 7.7 billion
dollars in Revenue
unbelievable
so I don't know you let me know are you
excited what's your favorite video games
what
my one of my favorite games was Destiny
and that's still going on that's a
10-year game
I stopped playing it because I'm I'm now
a big Call of Duty fan and you can see
that on live daily at error Griffin
gaming so I don't know what's your
favorite games but like Destiny was one
of those games and then all those
different series
that the sports franchise series but see
I don't like those because you have to
pay 59 every single year for basically
the same game
I think they should have made like some
sort of Subscription Service where the
stats are updating or something and they
just they just have a DLC for the game
as opposed to like oh I have to buy a
whole new game and then then they're
like forced to make certain changes to
make you feel like you got something new
so I don't like that model I think that
model is old I think like NBA 2K and
FIFA and hockey and those type of sports
games I think they're making they're
making a mistake but it's like they
don't care because like people are still
buying it but I stopped buying the
sports games if it wasn't for me
streaming and my fans asking hey can you
play this game I would never play those
games
you know then you have like the the
gaming subscriptions that you could get
right but so I don't know it's um
I think that this model right here I
think they're they're they're showing
that this works this is a model that
works spend a lot of money on a game put
everything into it really work on it get
out work out the Kinks put it online
boom here's a two billion dollar game so
you think 10 years and then with the
inflation and everything what they
probably make like 13 billion dollars
off of this game with all the little
in-game purchases that you have to uh to
buy and then the initial purchase of the
game this is probably going to be the
biggest game launch in history they'll
probably make a large portion of their
money back right away and then the
profits would just start rolling in but
pretty amazing thing to think about man
that they got that that this game is um
what it is two billion dollar game
speaking of crazy purchases let's go
into this one now
um this one's crazy man so there's some
iPhone that was at an auction so an
Apple iPhone from 2007 sells for a
hundred and ninety thousand dollars at
auctions apples were unopened four
gigabyte iPhone from 2007 smashes
records the exceedingly rate Factory
sealed first edition for iPhone is
exceptional condition attracted 28 bids
fetching nearly 400 times its original
price leaving all expectations shattered
Apple's Visionary Steve Jobs
revolutionized technology with this
groundbreaking Innovation so I think
it's one of the first iPhones that came
out this is one of those I have money I
have money to burn and so you like you
know
you're a collector and like I'm
surprised it wasn't Elon Musk that
bought this because he notoriously
overpays for products right I mean a
hundred and ninety thousand dollars for
the original iPhone like yuck
you know like this is one of those I
think I've been trying to find a list of
like the most expensive purchases in
history and
I guess you have to go it's actually
relative so it's probably not just the
actual amount of money because it's
probably always going to be a house you
know but what's you know relative to
what it is it's probably that's probably
a weird list but this is probably gonna
make the list right this has got to make
the list for a thing that was originally
a thousand dollars it sold for a hundred
and ninety thousand dollars I mean you
got to think like like I always say
Twitter like Twitter
buying Twitter for 44 billion dollars
was
the dumbest purchase in history there
isn't a worst waste of money than that
in my opinion but who knows in five six
years when he's selling ads and and he's
turned Twitter into a bank and he not
you know then the evaluation of the
companies at a hundred billion or
something I'll eat my words then but for
now that just seems like a really stupid
purchase and so does this but I guess
this is one of those I have a lot of
money and I have a little room in my
15 room eight bathroom mansion that I
put nonsense in and this is one of them
so you walk around and you're like oh
look at this it's like I did this
podcast X5 is the name of the podcast
and the guy that you know he runs them
but he's just a rich guy living in
Alabama that wanted to start a podcast
Network and good for him really cool
dudes by the way no shade on them but
the guy he's just like he's this wealthy
guy man just [__] wealthy guy and
he's got like a you know at first I
drive out to this really weird place and
I'm like where the hell am I is this how
you die is this like some Blair Witch
Project and it just like crappy looking
building go inside beautiful plush
studio with a garage in the back and the
dude had the Knight Rider car
that's some rich guy I got money to burn
[__] where he bought a Knight Rider car
and it was the original it had the
stupid steering wheel with the lights in
the front and you can press a button and
the music started and you could and it
had the original voice that's you know
you got money you're like oh yeah I want
that that's what this is
you know and you probably it was
probably at the auction where it was
like all like ego going on in there too
like a bunch of a bunch of rich people
and someone's like ah look at that
stupid phone I want it and then another
guy was like well I want it you know
then they were like oh no no no no so it
I think that at an auction
there's a few people at an auction
where they really want this
and then there's people at the auction
who are like I don't want you to have it
and that's why it goes you know that's
how I got up to 190 thousand dollars
this is like a fight this is a game
that's a rich people game right there
so weird stuff
weird stuff right there
but you know it is what it is guys
uh all right here's a weird let's go to
this weird story
um so here this poor sap
go to this look at this poor guy out of
at a at a game so they're putting a tarp
for
right so they're putting the tarp
because it's raining and one of the guys
fell and now he's trapped
he's trapped underneath trying to get
out
it's like
oh my God like imagine you're this guy
what if it was like even bigger and he
like he has to like crawl out of this I
mean I'm trying to think if I've ever
seen
one of these like weird you ever you
guys ever remember any like weird Sports
stories if you have them like put them
in the you know put them on the comments
I'm trying to think of some weird Sports
moments that I've seen like live and I
don't know I don't I don't remember ever
seeing anything like this I think the
weirdest Sports Experience I've I I've
been at a game one time was it was a
Laker game and I'm like I didn't I
didn't have great seats I'm like but
they're they're decent seats and then
like they were filming they were just
filming a John Travolta movie at the
time I forgot the name of that movie but
he had like long hair he was like a con
artist or I forgot the name of the movie
it was so long ago but like they just
were filming the movie and didn't tell
anybody so the the in them in the scene
John Travolta's at the game so they had
the other actors just kind of like there
that he was coming down and to talk to
them and so they just filmed this scene
of him walking into the you know running
into this the thing and I just remember
being like
is that John Travolta you know what I
mean like everybody was kind of looking
like what's going on over there and so
they just did it you know so that was
like a weird thing there I've never seen
anybody fall or like you know there's
always a lot of weird halftime swordfish
was it swordfish oh maybe it was
Swordfish
no no swordfish was with I don't think
John was John Travolta in that I don't
think he was in that that was Hugh
Jackman Hugh Jackman and Holly Berry was
John Travolta I don't think John
Travolta was in that dude
I don't think he was in that so
all right let me see if I talked about
oh yeah I think I talked about all those
stories Okay so
um let's go to
one of the last stories of the day right
now guys is
is this here
the house oversight plans a UFO hearing
after unconfirmed claims of Crash alien
spacecraft
this up a little bit there we go
you know let's do that too let's get it
even more yeah there we go
so
um
oh I also want to talk about this Tupac
story too I think that's weird
uh wait what is this crap here
wait let me
I don't want to I don't care about this
let me just let me just get off this
page I just wanted to see that what
they're talking about and talk about
this a little bit
um guys I
I I don't know how I feel about
aliens
okay you know like I don't know if
this is
you know like is this real you know and
if it is
why aren't we talking about it more
you know what I mean like why aren't we
talking about aliens more
like there's all these little stories
that you can kind of look up and I feel
like we're being distracted
I feel like there's so much things being
thrown at us that we can't tell what's
real what's new whether it's Trump or
whether it's uh you know whatever the
thing's going on global warming all like
trying to cancel people and the good
person police just dominating like you
know trying to like you did this 10
years ago you said this so now we have
to cancel you like all that stuff is
distracting us from like
what's really going on
like are you a believer that there is an
Area 51
that aliens have
because I don't know how I feel about it
because I'm not a Believer I think that
this let's say this this is how I feel
if there are aliens and they've been
here
so either
if they're here and they can they're
coming back and forth then we have
something to worry about because if they
have that kind of technology and they're
not helping us
then what are they doing what is this
some sort of sadistic
alien race who doesn't care about what's
going on or they're planning to ruin us
and so they could take over our planet
like what's their purpose like I don't
believe in this like oh they're just
watching us and they don't want to
interfere what if you see bad stuff
going on and you can fix it and you're
not doing anything like what are they
doing
what you know
or is it that some Interstellar
space aliens
they're you know they they crash landed
and they have no way because of our
limited technology and resources here to
get back so they've integrated into
society
is that it
are we some big experiment that has just
gone wrong and they're trying to fix it
you know or maybe they're just still
watching us to see like you know all
right let's see how they progress over
we're gonna take this in a thousand year
experiment and they're like okay and
they're like oh this isn't going well
I don't know
have they always been here are they the
reasons for like some of our major
discoveries but what I'm saying is
if the government is looking into it and
they're having some oversight committee
isn't it strange that that's not
dominating the headlines
what's bigger than
an alien ship
we have wreckage of an alien ship like
what story
or anything going on in the world is
bigger than that
isn't it strange to you
that
it's kind of just like huh we're just
kind of like you look at you it comes up
on your Instagram and you're like oh
aliens okay and then you just swipe
because you're like you want to see uh
the new dance video or or like for me my
Instagram is full of baby stuff now so
you know you sweet you swipe past the
aliens for 10 things to know about
newborns and you're like oh okay like
are we so inundated with information are
we so distracted that we are missing
the greatest discovery in human history
what are we doing
like isn't it
odd to you
whether you believe it or not believe it
or not
if it's true
like what
it would it's gonna that would change
the world
is it just me that things like this what
do you think tell me in your comments
are you worried about aliens are you are
you you think do we have something to
worry about or you think they've always
been here and they're finally going to
reveal themselves are are maybe they've
finally got in contact with their home
world and their home world is like oh
we're on the way to get you
and then it's like you know what like
what do you what do you think is
happening and why
aren't we
why isn't this dominating all the news
is what I'm saying
don't you think this should be like the
first thing on your feed is alien vessel
found like they already said they found
some a meteorite some in it's the first
time something from outside of our
galaxy or something has you know they
found in the Pacific Ocean or something
some Interstellar meteorite so it's like
okay is this the start of it
you know what what
what's going on
Mr Bubble says the only thing that would
unite everyone yeah I agree
yeah if we had some alien planet to
worry about yeah then it's gonna not
it's not gonna be like you know
it's like are we worried about who's
white and who's not who's black who's
not gay lesbian you know transgender all
the stuff that we're like focusing on
that makes us different that that we
love to like fight about then some green
alien comes and they're gonna be like
yeah you're all the same to us
it's gonna be funny when the white
people are gonna be like oh yeah we're
with you aliens and they're gonna be
like ah no you're just like them uh we
we've analyzed the DNA and you're not
any different and that's when we're
gonna all come together
you know what I mean it's gonna be it's
gonna be so strange but I don't know
I don't know guys I don't know you tell
me what you think
so when the let's distract ourselves
Department you know like I said uh
what's more important than aliens is
do they still investigate into Tupac
murder
new details emerge after home searched
in Tupac Shakur murder case man I
thought this case was closed but
apparently they are still uh
they're still looking for stuff here
breaking news in the Tupac Shakur murder
investigation so
let's get to know that they're going to
solve that case
right
they're gonna solve that I mean
um
I don't I don't are you a big Tupac fan
I don't know if this younger generation
can even appreciate
the guy's story and everything that
happened to him you know just the you
know a guy that he was going to like
almost like a Juilliard or something to
be like an actor then he and then he was
in what was that movie that he was in
where he was like a gangster and then
after that everything changed and he was
like this like figure and then he's
getting shot at and he's having a battle
with Biggie and and then he's killed and
then Biggie's killed and then here we
are
I mean
yeah somebody's like Tupac is alive in
the Bahamas well that would be that
would be terrible
what would you think if that were true
what if like it was revealed that there
was like you know some Island that like
Tupac's living on you know and he's just
he's just been there
you know he he's in like witness
protection because he like you know he I
don't know it's almost like Witness
Protection
it wasn't Poetic Justice it was juice
juice thank you
you got to watch juice before juice
Tupac was a certain person and then
after juice it's like he became that guy
from juice
and it turned him into a
multi-millionaire you know so I mean
people I don't know I don't know if it
was all fake I don't know if he was this
but he seemed like a real passionate
dude you know there's a story that like
they shot him
he shot he's dying and the police asked
him like
who did this and this the rumor is that
he said to the cop
[__] you and then died
I mean how gangster is that
oh man like that you want you want that
to be true right you want that to be
true you want that that Tupac went out
like I ain't no snitch and then just
died
I mean that just sounds crazy but you
know
let's listen guys look out for my
patreon episode of
spoiler alert spoiling with Griffin
because I want to go I'm going to go
into detail
about Idol that crazy show that was on
HBO Max I mean just one of the most
polarizing ridiculous shows I've ever
watched in my life so make sure you guys
check that out you know riffing with
Griffin
I got to get rid of the rid of that
title thing so always appreciate that
you guys are here hey if you want to
send me uh if you're a producer and you
got some beat did you just want to get
out there into the streets and you know
you send me for my rap Recaps I would
love that so once again make sure you
guys subscribe share all that
um I'm on Twitch which I'll be on Twitch
in about five six minutes
uh you should be a member there when I
go live for my patreon episodes I do it
live on for a subscriber only
subscriber only live broadcast and so
I'll do that on Twitch and then
you know you'll get that on patreon and
I appreciate the support I got a baby on
the way you know I'm trying to just do
more of my own stuff I really want to
grow my podcast so I can so I don't have
to do nothing else if you're up to me I
would if I could just do river with
girlfriend and gaming I'd be like cool
and then occasionally go do like some
voice over work for cartoons that's just
where I want to be at right now and of
course I'd obviously do stand up and
speaking of doing stand-up make sure you
guys come check me out this weekend if
you're in the Chicago area I'm gonna be
at Rosemont Zanies Rosemont come check
me out and then next the week after I'm
gonna be at the Irvine Improv one night
two shows July 20 28th Friday in Irvine
so you guys come check me out there and
you know what else I want to give a
shout out to my guy Joe Rogan I did a
funny sketch with
Blake Weber and Brent how do you say
Brent's last name if you go to my
Instagram guys oh you know what let me
let me go to my Instagram I'll show you
guys my stuff if you go to my Instagram
um where is it profile so we did this
funny sketch I mean let me just show
I'll show it to you guys Instagram video
you know
um we did this really funny sketch
oh wait wait wait where are we at
we did this funny sketch about the
carnivore diet you know where is it
get in here
oh let me start it over
oh man come on how do you start [__]
over on I hate that you know what I'll
do this and come back and we'll go back
so this
oh
can you guys hear that
I don't think you guys can hear it
okay
so
so I don't know if you guys can I don't
know if you heard that can you oh there
was no audio damn it I gotta see I got
way anyways there's this sketch I did
with with these two funny guys man Blake
Weber and Brent what do you get Brent's
last name right
um
how do you say Brent's last name
um Brent Pella yeah anyways two really
funny dudes and we're always like
writing things and he was so he said hey
let's do a sketch about the carnivore
diet so we did this uh it's really it's
on my Instagram so go check it out there
and then Joe Rogan hit me up last night
he was like dude what is this this is
hilarious because some carnivore doctor
grabbed it and posted it on his thing
and so Joe's all about carnivore so he
hit me up like man this is really funny
that he posted it on his page which I
thought was pretty cool to him so I
appreciate that so you know it's good to
have the comedy being part of the comedy
family the part comedy community is
always always very supportive so
um I gotta fix that audio for next time
but anyways guys
you know what time it is
oh yeah
with that rap recap
hear that beat and start the clap
again
tell your friends
about
uh ripping with Griffin
[Music]
oh James Cameron
gonna make a movie
[Music]
probably just smoke a doobie
they're gonna find out who did it
I don't know who did it
thanks for watching ripping with Griffin
[Music]
see you next week
stop and move your feet
[Music]
hit him with the woo-woo
go boo boo
Foo Rick Glassman is a juju
all right y'all
thanks for watching we're from with
Griffin and as always
see you next week
[Music]